[Musique]
bienvenue pour ce premier numéro de
l'année de paris saclay tenais je vous
souhaite une excellente année 2022 il
n'est jamais trop tard pour se souhaiter
le meilleur et le meilleur elle passe
par l'environnement et par exemple par
la valorisation des sols que faire des
dizaines de milliers de mètres cubes de
terre stérile excaver lors des
différents chantiers des terres qui
seraient bonnes à jeter et bien non le
pea paris saclay a décidé de valoriser
ces terres stériles en ajoutant du
compost végétal ce qui permet de les
réemployer autres initiatives
écologiques importantes et intéressantes
utilisez des chevaux sur les chantiers
et oui c'est possible rencontre avec
s'il désigne et sa jument pomme ensuite
on ira boire un verre dans un tout
nouveau lieu brave and co une brasserie
qui est située dans le quartier de
boulot vous pouvez même déguster une
bière brassée sur place oui ici sur le
territoire de paris saclay past and co
qui participera peut-être en fin d'année
au prochain marché de noël
retour sur la première édition du marché
de noël qui s'est donc déroulée place
marguerite torres était en décembre
retour en musique enfin que peut-il
faire en ce début d'année est bien pour
tout savoir il faudra regarder l'agenda
ce sera à la fin de cette émission
préserver l'environnement c'est une
volonté forte de le paix à paris saclay
et cela passe par la valorisation des
sols que faut-il faire des dizaines de
milliers de mètres cubes de terre
excavée sur les différents chantiers ce
sont des terres stériles alors faut-il
les jeter et bien non le père de paris
saclay avec le soutien de l'ademe et en
collaboration avec seul paysage
transforme ses des blés limoneux en
ajoutant du compost végétal ce qui
permet de les réemployer nos vastes
opérations qui parle de valoriser près
de 80 % du stock initial vous allez
comprendre comment en regardant son
reportage
l'établissement public d'aménagement
paris saclay en tant qu'aménageur
maîtres d ouvrage des espaces publics de
ce qu'on appelle le sud plateau est
générateur de mouvements de terre donc
il est paru nécessaire assez rapidement
de mettre en place des filières qui
éviterait une évacuation par camion de
ses stocks et donc ses stocks là qu'on a
mélangé avec du compost afin de rendre
ces lits mans inerte fertile ceci nous a
permis d'éviter une évacuation dans
cinquante mille mètres cubes de limon
par camion en dehors du plateau c'est
cette terre végétale nouvellement créée
qui a pouvoir maintenant être très
employé dans les espaces verts des
différents quartiers du plateau de
saclay nous avons tout d'abord commencé
le chantier en 2019 par une
caractérisation des des terres c'est à
dire qu'on est venu sur site pour
réaliser des sondages et définir en fait
le les différents matériaux qu'on
pouvait trouver sur ce site on y
installer un atelier de tri avec des
pelles mécaniques pour reformer des
cordons choix de limon qui sont
réutilisables soit de matériaux argileux
puisqu'ici on a beaucoup d'argile à
meulières non réutilisables donc ces
matériaux une fois validé par la
maîtrise d'oeuvre seul paysage
nous les avons pour les bons matériaux
ramener ici sur 7 sur cette aire de
stockage en collaboration avec
l'entreprise nous avons élaboré cette
plateforme sur laquelle nous nous
trouvons cette plateforme était
également le lieu ou n'a pu constituer
les mélange de terre amendes et avec du
compost puisque la fabrication de
substrats fertile repose sur le principe
de mélange de terre faiblement organique
avec du compost de déchets verts en
proportion est en caractéristiques
maîtrisé puis ces matériaux vont évoluer
sous couvert végétalisée comme on peut
le voir sur la plateforme et
le matériau va évoluer par bio turba
sion c'est à dire que le système
racinaire va permettre une aération et
une amélioration du matériau sous jacent
donc du coup toute cette toute cette
table de culture
va pouvoir va pouvoir servir desservir
tous les chantiers qu'il y as en plateau
de saclay côté palaiseau polytechnique
ou moulon qui est de l'autre côté
ce projet de remédiation des termes des
terres inertes en terre fertile a été en
partie subventionné par l'ademe pour sa
démarche innovante dans laquelle le ps
s'inscrit
[Musique]
autre initiative très originale pour
préserver les sols faire appel à des
chevaux oui ces rappels à des chevaux
sur les chantiers mais les des chevaux
avec des engins mécaniques pour par
exemple dégager des espaces naturels
rencontre avec sylvie des vignes et sa
jument pomme vous les avez peut être
croisés sur la zac de l'école
polytechnique ici même
[Musique]
donc je m'appelle sylvie des vignes je
suis gérante de l'entreprise aux
couleurs du cheval qui est basée dans
l'eure en normandie et donc c'est ma
jument pomme avec qui je travaille
actuellement sur ce chantier
alors on avait deux types de travaux à
réaliser sur
sur ce chantier j'ai travaillé déjà la
semaine dernière sur le débusquage des
arbres morts qui ont été préalablement
abattu donc j'avais trois zones de
dépôts l'idée c'était vraiment de
dégager toute une zone pour ensuite
pouvoir faire du des plantations
cette semaine je suis là avec pommes
pour le travail de sol donc
préparation pour les futures plantations
l'intérêt de travailler avec le cheval
que ce soit en débardage débusquage donc
sur le travail du bois ou sur le travail
du sol c'est vraiment la préservation
des sols le nom classement on peut être
sollicitée en traction animale soit sur
des zones qui ont déjà des valeurs
environnementales donc des zones natura
2000 les espaces naturels sensibles ou
là le cheval vient vraiment conforté en
fait cette préservation de
l'environnement qui est déjà en place et
donc on peut intervenir aussi bien sûr
sur du débardage que par exemple sur du
fauchage
donc sur sur des périodes bien
spécifiques pour pertes pas à porter
bébé milieu
ici je pense que la demande est un petit
peu différente puisque on est pas sur un
ms on n'est pas sur une zone natura 2000
mais il ya vraiment une volonté de
restauration écologique du lieu
donc effectivement je travaille à côté à
côté des pelleteuses qui crée des nous ç
en fait il y avait un gros problème dans
nos moments ici avec une grosse
problématique de mortalité des végétaux
là il ya un réaménagement de fait donc
bon c'est aussi intéressant de voir
qu'on peut combiner et l'action
mécanique et l'action du cheval mais
voilà je pense qu'il y avait sept cette
volonté de le pa2 de préserver le lieu
autant que possible
et maintenant je vous emmène dans un
tout nouveau lieu festif brasse 1 qu une
brasserie qui s'est installée dans le
quartier de moulon vous pourrez y
déguster une bière locale une bière
brassée ici même à paris saclay une
équipe de choc emmené par sarah
peaucellier et tiffany optant
[Musique]
bonjour à tous nous sommes des cif et
brasse enhco donc le brou pub qui se
trouve sur le plateau du long nous
sommes donc un bar à bière une
microbrasserie un restaurant nous sommes
ouverts en continu de 11 heures jusqu'à
23 heures 30 en semaine et jusqu'à
minuit et demi le vendredi et le samedi
on vous proposera des événements les
événements sportifs des événements
festifs
nous allons pouvoir vous proposer des
bières fait sur place en direct de notre
micro production et cela va permettre de
pouvoir nous proposer par la suite deux
événements en atelier de brassage
pour la carte nous vous proposons donc
un de bières différentes et pour la
carte de restauration nous allons vous
proposer une cuisine type brasserie sur
le midi nous avons une carte à
l'individuel et à l'assiette et le soir
nous allons pouvoir vous proposer des
planches à partager
[Musique]
on vous attend nombreux pour cette année
qui arrive
si vous êtes plutôt vin chaud vous avez
dû vous précipiter au premier marché du
campus urbain premier marché de noël et
s'est déroulée ici place marguerite eux
pleuraient au mois de décembre dernier
de la musique des produits locaux
notamment grâce à l'amiable locale un
commerce que vous connaissez
certainement beaucoup d'autres stands
sont accueillis les curieux et les
gourmands et au vu de cette première
édition d'autres devraient suivre tout
de suite les explications de marie crir
elle est chef de projet commerce et vie
urbaine a loupé à paris ça qui est
bienvenu au premier marché de noël du
campus de paris saclay ce qu'on peut
dire sur ce marché de noël c'est que il
a été vraiment co-construit est co
organisé entre les services de la ville
et les services de le paix à paris
saclay et donc on est très content de
pouvoir offrir aux premiers usagers du
campus et en particulier les étudiants
les commerçants mais également les
premiers habitants la possibilité de
venir acheter les cadeaux dernière
minute et de profiter un peu de l'esprit
de noël sur le campus
on a donc huit chalets qui ont été pris
par des commerçants et des artisans
locaux mais également un de ces chalets
qui a été pris par la mienne local
commerce que les habitants du campus
connaissent bien puisqu'il a ouvert
maintenant depuis deux ans sur le
quartier de moulon donc de l'autre côté
l'autre grand quartier du campus et
spécificités on a également un chalet
qui a été mis à disposition des
associations étudiantes et donc on est
très content parce que ça permet aussi
aux étudiants de venir se réunir dans ce
cadre un peu festif qu'est noël et de
s'approprier aussi le territoire et de
s'approprier cette place marguerite
perret qui est un peu structurantes
aussi pour ce quartier
[Musique]
l'ensemble des commerçants déjà implanté
sur ce quartier ont participé activement
à l'organisation de ce marché et en
particulier donc la boulangerie
pacifique le franprix le restaurant au
living room le tabac est également le
traiteur asiatique au food asia et sans
oublier la résidences adagio qui a été
également partie prenante pour
l'organisation de ce marché
on espère tous collectivement et
d'ailleurs les consommateurs avec
lesquels j'ai pu échanger ont tous envie
que ce soit reproduit et effectivement
on envisage éventuellement de renouveler
l'expérience chaque année puisque on
sent bien que cette place avait fait
pour vivre et que c'est une bonne
manière de s'approprier les lieux aussi
que de venir installer des installations
éphémères comme un marché de noël et que
ça permet aussi de faire qu'en plus et
ça permet aussi tout simplement la
rencontre entre les différents usagers
de ce territoire puisque quand on a des
grandes écoles des grandes entreprises
mais également des habitants on n'a pas
forcément tout de suite l'habitude de
venir arpenter les espaces publics les
utiliser et des opérations de ce type ça
permet aussi la rencontre entre ces
différents usagers avec évidemment les
artisans et les commerçants du
territoire qu'on souhaite évidemment
accompagné dans le cadre de notre
mission d'aménageur et je le répète en
collaboration bien entendu avec les
collectivités locales et en ce qui
concerne ce marché en particulier avec
la ville de palaiseau
[Musique]
notre agenda à présent studieux et
sportif si vous êtes concerné par
parcours sup ne ratez pas les journées
portes ouvertes post-bac 2022 de
l'université paris saclay scellé samedi
5 février 12 février et le mercredi 9
mars sport et sciences 3 2 1 partez une
exposition qui comme son nom l'indiqué
mais le sport et les sciences à
l'honneur au val fleuri à gif c'est
jusqu'au 20 février 2022 et enfin paris
saclay spring 2022 après une édition
100% digitale en 2021 paris saclay ce
prix il revient sur deux jours les 12 et
13 mai au sein de l'école polytechnique
deux jours pour découvrir échanger
rencontrer repérer les talents et les
pépites de demain notez bien ces deux
dates 12 et 13 mai pour paris saclay
spring mais d'ici là on aura l'occasion
de se reparler voilà c'est la fin de
cette émission merci à vous de l'avoir
suivi je vous souhaite encore une fois
une très belle année 2022 prenez soin de
vous on se retrouve très vite donc et
d'ici là restez informé sur le pap est
ce point fr
[Musique]